we're getting through this says The
Gambler I think it's really important
that we create a kind of Library where
people can understand what it took to
keep our country free and
action there is an era that has to be
recreated here and there is no way to
have this level of authenticity without
all of our great artists shout out to
colen four time Oscar winner stop
playing with Colleen Atwood is the
legend of Legends I feel so fortunate
that we had her Colin is incredible she
really brings the characters to the
costumes I started way before we started
shooting manufacturing the Leathers that
Pilots wore because no place in the
world had them and I needed for each
character three or four versions of
their
costume the target for today is
Berlin we did find a few b7s in the
world that do occasionally fly but they
weren't going to get us through produ
uction so we built 2
b7s all right boys huddle up we ended up
building full
exteriors and then all the interior
pieces that was pretty much a Year's
work this looks great every authentic
detail in here the combination of the
construction of the plane with content
walls gave the boys the real feeling of
Fighters going by and shooting at them
and I think it helped their reactions
and them really feeling what the terror
might be like like open fire let him
have it the volume is a gift it's
phenomenal the gimbal's moving if you're
looking at that plane it soon's pass you
know you're in the plane you're
fighting this project it's an absolute
dream come true and you end up getting
in this flow where it becomes your life
you just feel so blessed to be a part of
[Music]
it